you made me like this you don't care
about me all you care about is money
you're nothing but a pimp Kara
don't you call me Kara I'm your mother
oh so I can call my mother a pimp but I
can't call her by her first name shut up
Marquis I don't want to hearing you talk
to me like that you are ruining her oh
I'm ruining her so I guess I guess it
was my fault that your precious little
underage piece of jade got herself drunk
and decided to hook up a scumbag Nick at
a nightclub I am the one that saved her
you were probably too busy sucking down
a bottle of wine to even know that she
snuck out that's it Marquis you are done
talking to me like that and you are done
with this family I see so the pimp lost
control of one [ __ ] and now she's
afraid to lose the other
you just have to stay here for 30 days
and then your probation will be over
what about men in there forget about it
do you have any idea how beautiful you
are right now I want to go out begging
like Marilyn
little help
I'll make sure they remember you I'm
nothing without the attention it's like
a drug where you just you need more and
more eventually you don't care what you
got a dedicated would you go out tonight
and film something for me
are you gonna kill me anyway you want
you
you